What is the impact
of clustering?
Clustering members
within each cost bucket
yielded better predictions for
heart attacks within clusters.
Grouping patients
in clusters exhibits
temporal diagnostic
patterns within nine months
of a heart attack.
These patterns can
be incorporated
in the diagnostic rules
for heart attacks.
The approach shows that using
analytics for early heart
failure detection through
pattern recognition
can lead to interesting
new insights.
The findings here are reinforced
by results from our research.
IBM, Sutter Health, and
Geisinger Health Systems
partnered in 2009 to
research analytics tools
in view of early detection.
Steve Steinhubl, a
cardiologist from Geisinger,
wrote, "our early
research showed
the signs and symptoms of
heart failure in patients
are often documented
years before diagnosis.
The pattern of documentation can
offer clinically useful signals
for early detection of
this deadly disease."